[Música]
este 26 de octubre se cumplió un mes
desde que Colombia y Venezuela
reabrieron su frontera que había
permanecido encerrada al paso vehicular
durante siete años según el gobierno
colombiano las cifras del comercio entre
ambos países siguen creciendo pero los
habitantes opinan distinto
en la recta final de la segunda vuelta
de la selección especiales en Brasil los
candidatos se apresuran a seguir sumando
votos el gobierno del presidente Yahir
bolsonaro aumentó la ayuda social a
medio millón de personas en condición de
pobreza lo que le ha ganado
simpatizantes de la izquierda
y los estadounidenses también irán a las
urnas el 8 de noviembre para renovar la
cámara de representantes y un tercio del
senado uno de los temas que parece mover
al electorado es la economía del país
que atraviesa por la inflación más alta
registrada desde 1982
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en francés 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz este 26 de
octubre se cumplió un mes de la
reapertura de la frontera Colombo
venezolana un acto producido en el marco
del cambio de gobierno en Colombia y que
cumplía una de las promesas de la
campaña del presidente izquierdista
Gustavo Petro a pesar de que esta medida
generó expectativas en la reanudación
veloz del comercio este continúa siendo
incipiente los ciudadanos de ambos lados
de la frontera aseguran que para ellos
los cambios no han sido visibles Manuel
acano tiene los detalles
entre cantos y ovaciones Colombia y
Venezuela celebraban la reapertura de su
frontera compartida después de siete
años de cierre el acto despertaba
Esperanza ambos costados de los puentes
Simón Bolívar y Francisco de Paula
Santander Pero un mes después las
expectativas se han ido diluyendo para
los habitantes de la zona poco ha
cambiado porque claro
los carritos Y eso para poder uno ya
facilitar más la pasada porque esta
pasadita aquí siempre es difícil
porque nos perjudica el trabajo pasar la
mercancía eso Entonces la ayuda de uno
pero nos regresa no lo dejan pasar al
mercancía para acá los gobiernos
aseguran que se está llevando a cabo un
proceso gradual porque el comercio se
hace entre gente entre empresarios
entonces en la medida que tú tengas
Claridad de que ese día ese canal es es
seguro puedo decir la operaciones se
están dando tú va a direccionar más
operaciones por esa vía que por otra
vías alternativa las cifras denotan un
éxito moderado según el Ministerio de
comercio colombiano desde la apertura se
hicieron negocios por 2,25 millones de
dólares y pasaron 1552 toneladas de
carga de importaciones y exportaciones
se calcula que 67 camiones de carga han
cruzado por los puentes
muchos siguen siendo los retos Uno de
ellos es combatir el contrabando que
según la cámara de integración económica
venezolano colombiana ha aumentado desde
la reapertura y que en este año ha
generado aproximadamente 900 millones de
dólares y seguimos ahí en Colombia 16
personas que habían sido secuestradas
por disidencias de la extinta guerrilla
de las FARC fueron liberadas el grupo
bautizado a la segunda marquetalia FARC
que continuó con su lucha armada
desprendiéndose de la desmovilización
acordada con el gobierno de Juan Manuel
Santos por el que ganó el premio Nobel
de paz informó que dejó en libertad a
estos ciudadanos como un gesto de
compromiso con la paz Total que busca el
actual presidente de Gustavo Petro
el estado boliviano y los dirigentes de
los mineros cooperativistas auríferos
llegaron a un acuerdo el principal punto
de discusión fue el régimen de
tributación de 4,8% al valor de sus
ventas de oro el régimen tributario que
se aplicará al sector de las
cooperativas mineras auríferas ahora se
presentará al parlamento y tendrá un
carácter prioritario según el ministro
de economía Marcelo Montenegro
inicialmente el gobierno había
establecido un impuesto del 5%, mientras
que los dirigentes del sector fijaron un
tope del 4,5%. el Ministerio de economía
estimó que a septiembre de esa gestión
el sector de las cooperativas auríferas
consiguió ingresos por 2.000 millones de
dólares por lo que es necesario que
tribute al tesoro de la nación en Brasil
las universidades públicas se enfrentan
una difícil situación presupuestaria
algunas de ellas corren el riesgo de no
poder pagar los salarios de sus
empleados una de las razones para este
déficit se debe a que durante sus cuatro
años de mandato el presidente la
reelección y árbol sonaro realizó varios
recortes a los presupuestos destinados a
la educación el tema pasó a ser parte
del debate Nacional de Cara a la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
previsto para este 30 de octubre
un antiguo hospital psiquiátrico
construido hace más de 120 años en la
universidad Federal de Río de Janeiro a
la que solo le queda esta escalera de
madera de su pasado
esplendorgate
algún lío es una falta de mantenimiento
que representa un peligro permanente
para estudiantes como Jessica piñeiro
que estudia ciencias sociales
toda la universidad está hecha de madera
Así que si hay un incendio se acabó
porque no hay una salida de emergencia
no hay un protocolo de evacuación
desde el comienzo de la pandemia también
se han suspendido miles de becas de
estudio e investigación sin explicación
alguna al igual que esta universidad
otras 68 se encuentran en situación
preocupante en Brasil de 2019 al 2022 el
presupuesto de las universidades
públicas federales se ha recortado en un
50 por ciento
estos estudiantes han condenado al
fracaso las intenciones del gobierno de
privatizar su gestión instituciones
vistas como una amenaza por el gobierno
en las universidades han surgido los
mayores movimientos anti bolsonaros en
2019 más de 100.000 estudiantes se
reunieron frente a nuestra universidad
para protestar fue la primera gran
movilización contra bolsonaro al inicio
de la pandemia Así que creo que siente
que es un polo de resistencia contra él
por eso nos ataca de vuelta tras
bloquear más de 500 millones de euros
del presupuesto universitario federal
Justo antes de las elecciones Jair
bolsonaro encendió la llama
ese día miles de estudiantes se
manifestaron en Río una movilización en
las calles y en redes sociales que según
Jessica obligó al gobierno a dar marcha
atrás y congelar el presupuesto Solo
hasta diciembre cuando el pueblo sale a
la calle puede cambiar las cosas cada
vez que nos manifestamos conseguimos que
el Gobierno regule ya sea en la calle o
en redes sociales como Jessica estos
jóvenes estudiantes constituyen uno de
los focos electorales más importantes
para el candidato de izquierdas Lula que
ha prometido dar prioridad a la
educación y al acceso a la universidad
se gana Estados Unidos también irá a las
urnas para renovar la cámara de
representantes y un tercio del senado a
menos de dos semanas de estos comicios
de medio término la economía se mantiene
como una de las principales
preocupaciones de los electores en medio
de la inflación más alta registrada
desde 1982
una economía golpeada en una época de
campaña por esos días para muchos
estadounidenses el aumento del costo de
vida es el tema principal para estas
elecciones en septiembre la inflación
interanual alcanzó un 8.2%. la más alta
desde 1982 crisis una madre de tres
hijos pide ayuda
ni siquiera puedo llevarlos para tomar
un helado solo algo tan pequeño como eso
y siento que nunca voy a recuperar este
tiempo nunca recuperaré este tiempo con
ellos
la inflación Es evidente en los
alimentos los servicios básicos y en los
precios de la vivienda y a dos semanas
de las elecciones de medio término las
cuales definirán si los demócratas
continuarán manteniendo la mayoría en el
congreso o si los republicanos
repuntarán se espera que les pase
factura por lo que este miércoles el
presidente Joe biden anunció que tomará
medidas contra las llamadas tarifas
basura refiriéndose a los sobregiros
ocultos y por Mora entre otros de bancos
y entidades privadas que según su
administración le ahorraría a sus
ciudadanos 3000 millones de dólares
anuales
hoy mi administración está anunciando
nuevas acciones para reducir el costo de
la vida cotidiana de las familias
estadounidenses para poner más dinero en
los bolsillos de los ciudadanos de clase
trabajadora y de ingresos medios para
responsabilizar a las grandes
corporaciones Y estos pasos comenzarán
inmediatamente a salvar a las personas
colectivamente
esta misma semana un tribunal Federal
bloqueo temporalmente el plan de alivios
a estudiantes anunciado en agosto una de
las promesas de campaña de baile que
pretendía condenar los pagos de
préstamos universitarios federales en
enero de 2023 y beneficiaría a más de
700 mil personas
vamos a Honduras el barrio Villanueva en
el este de la capital Tegucigalpa
amaneció custodiado por unos 200
policías que según las autoridades
estarán allí de forma permanente ante la
amenaza de pandilleros que no obligado a
los residentes a abandonar sus hogares
para ser ocupados por ellos los
uniformados registraron vehículos y
hacían quitarse la camisa a personas
sospechosas para constatar si tenían
tatuajes identificativos de grupos
criminales Este martes en redes sociales
circularon videos en los que se veían a
vecinos del sector huyendo con sus
pertenencias ante un ultimátum dado por
la pandilla barrio 18
terminado no solamente en actividades de
prevención sino que también de
investigación e inteligencia
nada de poder brindar con hijos de
seguridad que la gente retome la
tranquilidad obviamente atacar también a
qué estructuras de crimen organizado que
están afectando o trabajando en la zona
y que podamos identificar algunos
objetivos específicos hasta que este
Informativo en francés 24 Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]